we're told divide the polynomials the
form of your answer should either be
just a clean polynomial or some
polynomial plus some constant over X
plus 2 where P of X is a polynomial and
K is an integer fair enough and if we
were doing this on Khan Academy as a
screenshot from Khan Academy it we would
have to type this in but we're just
going to do it by hand and like always
pause this video and try to do it on
your own before we work through it
together all right now let's work
through it together and what we're
trying to do is divide X plus 2 into 3x
to the third power plus 4 x squared
minus 3x plus 7 and so like always we
focus on the highest degree terms first
X goes into 3x to the third power how
many times 3x squared times we'd want to
put that in the second degree column 3x
squared 3x squared times 2 is 6x squared
3x squared times X is 3x to the third
power there's something very meditative
about algebraic long division anyway we
want to subtract what we just wrote from
what we have up here so let's subtract
and these characters cancel out and then
4x squared minus 6x squared is negative
2x squared bring down that negative 3x
and now we would want to say hey how
many times does X go into negative 2x
squared well it would go negative 2x
times put that in our first-degree
column negative 2x times 2 is negative
4x negative 2x times X is negative 2x
squared now we want to subtract what we
have here in orange from what we have up
here in teal so we either put a negative
around the whole thing or we distribute
that negative and that becomes a
positive that becomes a positive and so
this is equal to the x squared terms
cancel out negative 3x plus 4x is just
going to be a straight-up X bring down
that 7x plus 7 how many times does X go
into X well one time let me do it use a
new color
year so how many times does X go into X
it goes one time put that in the
constant column 1 times 2 is 2 1 times X
is X we want to subtract these
characters and we're left with 7 minus 2
is 5 and so we can rewrite this whole
thing as and we deserve it I guess a
little bit of a drumroll 3 x squared
minus 2x plus 1 plus the remainder 5
over X plus 2 one way to think about is
hey I have this remainder after I'd have
to keep dividing it by X plus 2 if I
really want to figure out exactly what
this is now if I wanted these
expressions to be completely identical I
would put a condition on the domain that
X cannot be equal to negative 2 because
if X was equal to negative 2 we'd be
dividing by 0 here but for the purposes
of this exercise you just have to input
you just have to input this part right
over here you'd have to type it in which
I guess isn't the easiest thing to do in
the world but it's worth doing alright
see you in the next video